hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take we can turn now
to the other really significant story of
the day and NATO says that it thinks a
missile that landed in Poland killing
two people is likely to be from
Ukrainian air defenses now that view has
been disputed by Ukraine but following a
huge barrage of attacks across Ukraine
it of course has further rational up the
tensions between the west and Russia
with talk of invoking article 4 of the
NATO treaty well we can speak now to
Lord Peter Ricketts the former National
Security advisor and foreign office at
permanent secretary thank you so much
for being with us
um NATO say the missile is likely
Ukrainian Ukraine are disputing that
what is your sense
well I think the most important point is
that this incident only happened because
Ukraine had been under this massive
bombardment by the Russians against
their civilian infrastructure
um so that I think is the most important
thing that was happening yesterday
um whoever fired this missile it was
only because of that if it was a
Ukrainian in missile which looks more
and more likely it was because they were
firing in self-defense against this
incoming barrage of Russell missiles so
I'm sure the experts will tell us pretty
quickly when we are there whose missile
it was but the bigger background is that
this is one of the dangers one of the
things that happens when Russia behaves
like this going to war with the
neighboring countries
of course Poland is a member of NATO is
this the kind of thing that could
trigger a NATO response
it's worth just remembering what article
4 and article fiber about Article 4 of
the NATO treaty is consultations that's
effectively what's been happening today
the NATO Council met they pulled
information they expressed solidarity
with Poland and they said they're
keeping close touch with events Article
5 I mean if a member State Fields is
under an armed attack and that's the
Criterion an armed attack then NATO
members have agreed to act collectively
but the NATO treaty it's a political
treaty it's not a legal commitment and
each nation is free to decide what kind
of support it can give so it doesn't put
you on an escalator to you know
inevitable military conflict but it is a
collective defense vehicle now if this
was an errant Russian missile that went
Australian hit Poland that's hardly a
deliberate armed attack on Poland it
would be a very different thing if the
Russians made a deliberate attack on a
Polish military installation then we
really would be into issue of how NATO
would respond on Military
and it's interesting isn't it do you
feel that because of you know the
alliance and the consequences that could
have that Russia is I guess holding back
slightly when it comes to other
countries other than Ukraine
yes definitely I mean I think Putin you
know he's megalomaniac about Ukraine but
he understands the power of NATO and
this power of deterrence that if he does
deliberately attack a NATO State there
will be an armed response from NATO I
think there's no doubt about that and
he's got no doubt about that Ukraine of
course is not a member state of NATO
it's a close partner it's being
supported by NATO but it doesn't benefit
yet from that Collective guarantee which
effectively says you attack a member of
NATO and NATO will come back at you very
hard that has worked so far that red
line has been respected by the Russians
assuming that this was not a deliberate
attack by Russia on Poland which I
really don't think it was
I was reflecting a bit early today about
you know the war in Ukraine where all
the appalling images that we've seen
about all the discussions you know that
we've had and the international
discussions as well
and just thinking how I just cannot
really see a way out of it frankly right
now
is there any path that you can see for
an end of the war
I mean I think you're right
um I hear talk about people saying
there's got to be a negotiated solution
you know we've got to be a peace
settlement here I mean I don't think
that after all they've been through the
ukrainians are about to do a deal with
Russia which leaves Russia in possession
of some of their territory nor do I
think Putin is about to do a complete
unconditional withdrawal for all his
groups so I'm afraid what this is going
to head up to is a stalemate over the
winter where more or less in the
position the forces are now and then
probably more fighting next year I guess
in the end some sort of armistice or
truce a bit like we've had in Korea for
the last 70 years where there is a line
of Separation which is
um overseen by International
peacekeeping forces but neither side
have accepted that they've won or lost
them there is no durable piece that's
the most likely I can see from this it's
not a good one for Europe or for Ukraine
but it's certainly better the Ukraine
you know than if the Russians had
succeeded in their original objective
I've got analysis uh to hear but I do
you know accept the kind of I guess
accuracy of what you you're saying Lord
Richard good talk uh thank you very much
for being on the program